how's it going I'm misty Kingma and did
you see that Super Bowl no I missed it
cuz I died in an accident and that's the
first reason that the Super Bowl
commercials sucked this year all those
emotions not only will this dead kid
haunt my dreams forever but it seemed
like every other ad was trying to make
me sob uncontrollably look I'm glad the
Budweiser puppy and his horse the gang
defeated that wolf but that's not even
the worst of it is there anything sadder
than getting into a car and seeing your
dad crying yeah there is getting out of
a different card seeing your other dad
crying combine those with the Dove ad
even I'm ready to be a proud daddy
glasses tear then they tried to make me
feel better with these terrible ideas
like somehow pouring coca-cola on my
laptop will make me happy or paying at
McDonald's with my lovin and for your
table today you just pay with love it so
you might have sex with you know instead
of paying with cash you just show us
some lovin so have to be you cache of
sex with you
that would be prostitution just like a
smile at a stranger am i smile you mean
no I don't mean sex oh so just like peel
them up
Oh reason number two that the ads sucked
is that the celebrity cameo formula is
tired look I can poke fun of myself or
hey remember me from that movie or that
TV show or I'm incredibly irresistible
Marsha Marsha Marsha haha me seven
Buscemi but seriously come up with some
new ideas and number three though weird
commercials are fun but they still have
to be funny who's writing these now the
scripts for these seem like someone got
a hold of bad magnet poetry and then it
inspired a fever dream it's like they're
more interested in weirding us out than
making us laugh oh good job advertisers
I now associate your branded a confusing
waste of time okay okay I know that
every ad was terrible luckily the king
was so much better than the commercials
you know I think I might just be in a
bad mood because I had to research this
whole list online and I had to watch an
ad before I could watch an ad that's it
for hashtag news this week hit like if
you want to join that puppy's horse gang
and tell us in the comments which
commercials you love and which ones you
subscribe to see more hash tag news
I'm Missy Kingma and I'm in love with
dancing
shake that Carly